given the coordinates of two points how
do we find the equation of the line
passing through them we have been given
the coordinates of a and B here how do
we find the equation of the line passing
through a and B in the previous session
we have seen the slope-intercept form y
is equal to MX plus B M is the slope and
B is the y-intercept
to find the equation of this line let's
try to find the slope first if X comma Y
and x1 comma y1 are the coordinates of
the two points then the slope will equal
Y minus y1 over X minus x1 we have the
coordinates of the two points here if we
assume a to be X comma Y and B to be x1
comma y1 then the numerator would be 2
minus minus 2 and the denominator 3
minus minus 1 this gives us the slope of
the line as 1 we have M and we need to
find B it's easy if the slope is 1 this
can be written as y is equal to X plus B
to get B just substitute one of these
values here as both points lie on the
line if we substitute 3 in place of X
and 2 in place of Y we get 2 is equal to
3 plus B the value of B is minus 1 y is
equal to X minus 1 is the equation of
the line that passes through a and B
just to understand it a bit better
how will the line look we have the slope
as 1 and y-intercept as minus 1 it means
the line passes through 0 comma minus 1
how will the line look on the coordinate
plane the line passes through 0 comma
minus 1 and as the slope is positive the
line will look a bit like this we try to
draw the line using the slope and the
y-intercept just to understand it better
an easier way of course would have been
to plot points a and B and then draw a
line passing through them anyway so the
equation of the line is y is equal to X
minus 1 on the coordinate plane let's
assume we have a line like this parallel
to Y axis and passes through 3 comma 0
the slope-intercept form is y is equal
to MX plus B what is the slope and the y
intercept of this line as the run is 0
the slope of this line is undefined and
as it does not intersect the y axis
anywhere it does not have a y-intercept
the equation of the line is X is equal
to 3 here's an interesting question for
you what do you think will be the slope
and the y intercept of this line which
is parallel to the x axis it has no tilt
the rise is 0 the slope of this line
will be 0 as it meets the y axis at 2
the y intercept will be 2 and the
equation of this line is y equals 2
you